[MUSIC PLAYING]
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA AMIN: Since
the Industrial Revolution
began 250 years ago,
people have been
burning fossil fuels
like coal and oil
to generate electricity.
Hi, I'm Professor Nor
Aisha Saidina Amin,
professor of
chemical engineering,
and a visiting fellow with
the MIT UTM Sustainable Cities
Program.
My research is focused
on renewable energy,
and today I am going
to talk about climate
change and renewable energy.
The primary product of
burning of fossil fuels
is carbon dioxide.
For centuries, the amount
of carbon dioxide emissions
in the atmosphere was
300 parts per million.
But carbon dioxide have
increased dramatically
and reached an
unprecedented value
of about 400 parts per million.
High levels of carbon
dioxide emissions
are linked to
climate change, which
has led to increasing
temperatures, melting glaciers,
rising sea level, changing
rain and snow patterns,
and also drought, floods,
and other extreme events.
Climate change is
an important issue,
and reducing carbon
emission is a challenge.
In December 2015, world
leaders convened in Paris
to discuss the reduction of
carbon emissions and climate
change impacts at a United
Nations Global climate
conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: There is no doubt
that the global climate change
agreement we seek must be
part of what Paris has become.
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA
AMIN: Even Hollywood
is taking a public
stand on this issue.
SPEAKER 2: And the Oscar
goes to Leonardo DiCaprio.
[CHEERING]
LEONARDO DICAPRIO:
Climate change is real.
It is happening right now.
It is the most urgent threat
facing our entire species.
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA
AMIN: One of the ways
to address climate
change is to replace
fossil fuels with renewable
energy for electricity
production.
Carbon emissions from
renewable energy power plants
are much lower compared to those
that run with fossil fuels.
According to the Energy
Information Administration,
although there are plenty
of renewable resources
available on Earth, only 10%
of the world's energy output
is from renewable sources.
Types of renewable
energy include
solar, geothermal,
wind, and biomass.
There are many
lessons that can be
learned from Malaysia's success
with using renewable energy.
Given Malaysia's
tropical biodiversity,
conversion of biomass to
energy is a promising approach
to establishing sustainable
energy production.
JOHN WOODLEY:
Malaysia will also be
an excellent example
where there is
plenty of agricultural waste.
And it could be a
wonderful idea to try
to use that waste in a way which
brings a little bit of value
to your community, to the
country, but at the same time,
can help us to reduce
carbon dioxide emissions.
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA
AMIN: Situated in Johor,
the most southern state in
peninsula Malaysia, Iskandar,
Malaysia is a new
development region that
advocates low carbon emission.
Most of its carbon
dioxide emission
are from the electricity
and heating sector.
As documented in
their low carbon plan.
Iskandar, Malaysia is
projected to be a sustainable
city by 2025 with only $18.9
million tons of carbon dioxide
emissions, a 40% reduction
from 2005 levels.
How can this Iskandar,
Malaysia achieve this target?
One of the methods
is to utilize waste
from the oil pump industry to
generate heat and electricity.
Iskandar, Malaysia is easily
accessible to large areas
of oil palm plantation.
The oil pump industry produces
waste such as empty fruit bunch
and palm oil mill effluent.
Empty fruit bunch is the residue
you produced when palm fruit is
taken from a fresh fruit
bunch in the initial process
of a palm oil production.
Palm oil mill effluent is
the voluminous liquid waste
that comes from the
sterilization and clarification
processes in milling oil palm.
By utilizing waste,
carbon dioxide emissions
can be significantly
reduced and make the air
in the region cleaner
and healthier.
One way to measure
carbon dioxide emissions
is to use an
integrated model that
takes into account direct
and indirect carbon dioxide
emissions.
The concept of the
model used to probe
quite a systematic and
comprehensive carbon accounting
to evaluate carbon
performance, as well
as to determine the
potential carbon emission
reduction in the process.
The model calculates carbon
dioxide emissions from three
by biomass power plants-- the
bio-xcell plant, Kulim group
plant, and Ronser biogas plant.
Initially, carbon accounting
centers for each process
is divided into smaller units.
Next, the total monthly
carbon emission equivalent
is determined, followed by
calculation of the carbon
dioxide emissions and
carbon emission index
across the carbon
performance indicators.
Strategies for reduction
of carbon emissions
are then implemented.
The five main
emission contributors
are identified as carbon
performance indicators.
These are fuel, water, and
electricity consumption.
And also waste water and
solid waste generation.
Empty fruit bunch is
fed into Bio-Xcell Plant
to generate steam
and electricity.
Empty fruit bunch is
shredded and then formed
as solid pellets.
The pellets are used as
fuels for the boilers
to produce steam.
The steam turbine then
generates electricity.
Meanwhile, Kulim and Ronser
utilize palm oil mill effluent.
The effluent is retained
in an anaerobic digester
to produce bio gas.
The gas runs the turbine
to generate electricity.
The total monthly
carbon dioxide emissions
before and after
the implementation
of the reductions strategies
are exhibited in figure one,
showing a 27% emissions
reduction at Bio-Xcell,
15% at Kulim, and 41% at Ronser.
Figure two compares the
carbon emission index
after implementing the
reduction strategies.
In general, all
performance indicators
show reduced emissions
after innovative strategies
are implemented.
In Bio-Xcell, the
carbon emission index
for fuel and water consumption
decreased significantly
after solid, empty fruit bunches
replaced the shredded ones.
In addition, a reduction
of solid waste generation
in runs of bio gas
was also registered
after water from the
effluent is recycled.
Carbon dioxide emissions
can be easily predicted
using the income model.
A power plant that utilizes
biomass contributes
less to climate change since
the carbon dioxide released
is absorbed by trees
through photosynthesis.
The process is cyclical.
The industry could
play a big role
in reducing carbon
dioxide emissions
by switching to renewable energy
for generating electricity.
[MACHINERY MOTOR]
HO CHIN SIONG: The key
players-- the key players
for CO2 reduction has to be
also from the private sector.
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA AMIN:
Globally electricity generation
from renewables, and
particularly from biomass,
is increasing.
Biomass supplies such
as pump or mill effluent
is steady due to the number of
oil pump mills in the region
as stated by Dr. Azhar Aziz
of Gait Rungkai company.
AZHAR AZIZ: I will say it's
very, very valuable Very
significantly valuable because
based on the number of palm oil
mills in the country,
as of 2014, there
are at least 480 mills in the
country, including [INAUDIBLE].
So from this huge number of oil
mills, there are [INAUDIBLE].
It's just a matter of how we
are going to maximize this.
Because to me, it's not being
maximized in terms of effort
to reducing the carbon
emission in the country.
NOR AISHAH SAIDINA AMIN:
The significant decline
in capital costs for
electrical generation
suggests that investment
in renewable energy
is economically viable.
The utilization of
renewable energy waste
for re-powering power plants
could help realize Iskandar,
Malaysia's low carbon goals.
Since biomass emits
less carbon dioxide
compared to fossil fuels,
the move to clean energy
could reduce the magnitude
of climate change risks.
Renewable energy
is the way forward
to a wonderful more
sustainable world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]